hey guys I'm gonna answer a question can
I eat these vegetables on a ketogenic
diet well let's go ahead and talk about
this because there's a lot of confusion
so we're gonna talk about like the beets
the carrots the peas the tomatoes and
I'm gonna throw in potato corn art
artichoke too because they are they're
kind of fall in that category so if we
look at beets beets are really high in
potassium
I'm talking like 442 milligrams per cup
so all of these are based on one cup and
then the carbs are 13 grams and the
sugar is 9 grams so between the carbs
and the sugar the sugar is the most
important thing to look at because you
want to keep the sugar down really
really really low so if something has a
higher carbohydrate it might break down
the sugar very very slow if the fiber is
high versus high sugar it breaks down
and sugar really really fast regardless
of how much fiber but fiber does buffer
it so okay so the beet has about 9 grams
of sugar it's pretty high protein is 2.2
but look at this fiber is 3.8 so it has
a good amount of fiber which will tend
to buffer that so the question is should
you eat beets if you're trying to get in
ketosis probably not a good idea
however if you're happy with your weight
like myself go ahead and start eating
the beets because they have a lot of
good benefits for the liver for
nutrition good for detox of the gall
bladder that type of thing so generally
though if you're trying to get in
ketosis probably not a good idea to eat
beets okay the carrot 195 milligrams of
potassium again potassium is necessary
to help lower insulin so we want that
very high look at this six grams of
carbs that's pretty low compared to a
beet it's like half sugars are 2.9 grams
so that is very very low compared to a
beet protein not a lot of protein half
the fiber so I would say carrots would
be okay to consume Anna ketogenic diet I
don't think you're gonna have a hard a
problem with that because of these two
are very very low and plus all I mean
just have some
fiver so I wouldn't try to avoid carrots
okay all right the P peas snap peas or
dis regular piece 354 milligrams of
potassium it's pretty high 21 grams of
carbs is pretty high 8 grams of sugar
pretty high look how much protein eight
grams of protein wow that's interesting
that's probably ever hear a pea protein
before well that's why you don't hear of
karat protein do you and then we got 7
grams of fiber that's pretty high so
peas I probably would stay away from
peds simply because of the higher level
of sugar okay all right tomatoes 292
milligrams of potassium four point eight
grams of carbs it's that's pretty low
that's actually lower than carrots three
point two grams of sugar that's still
pretty low I mean it's like just a
little bit more than carrots so tomatoes
are probably a better thing to consume
so far than any eat other things we
talked about okay so it's kind of tied
with Cara but tomato is pretty pretty
low and then we have one point one gram
of protein 1.5 grams of fiber
okay not as much fiber as the pea but
still there's a little bit of fiber and
they're kind of similar to a carrot okay
so I would say okay consume tomatoes on
a ketogenic diet so so far our carrot
and tomato are okay but not beat in no
not peace now potato 897 milligrams of
potassium that is a tremendous amount
and then we got 37 grams of carbs that's
a lot of carbs and then but look at this
we got one point seven grams of actual
sugars so it's low but we know this type
of starch does break down into sugar
faster than we'd like it
4.3 grams of protein is pretty high and
look how much fiber 4.7 grams so potato
even though it has potassium this is the
culprit right here there's 37 thing so
that's the problem with this it's the
it's way way higher than for
a DIN tomato or a six six carbs okay but
it is low in sugar so if you're trying
to appear a child let's say your kids
are younger this would be potatoes would
be good I would do sweet potatoes and
yam red potato make sure they're organic
it's not a bad food but this may slow
you down losing weight okay now corn 476
milligrams of potassium it's pretty high
a hundred and twenty three grams of
carbs so this is why we do not want to
consume corn in addition to all the
corners GML so we don't want to do that
and then one gram of sugar okay well
that's good but still it's such a starch
16 grant I was really surprised that
corn has 16 grams of protein I just find
that hard to believe but that was what
the sources said I'm not sure with the
fibrous but I don't know corn protein I
don't know I don't know that doesn't
make sense to me okay
artichoke six hundred and forty four
milligrams of potassium so it comes in
second place just behind potato and then
we have carbs two hundred and sixty nine
grams oh my goodness that is it beats
all the other vegetables for the amount
of carbs so this is really high in carbs
per cup and look at this 14 grams of
sugar artichoke is the worst thing you
can eat on a ketogenic diet don't eat it
now protein 3 3 grams fiber is 2.4 okay
so I'm going to recommend that you stick
with the carrot and tomato and probably
not do these other ones okay all right
thank you for watching I'll see you the
next video